BOMBER.
WE'LL FOLLOW THIS NEWS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR.
WE'RE GOING TO START NOW WITH
OUR BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE FIRST.
IN OTHER NEWS, THE PRESIDENT IS
SLAMMING HILLARY CLINTON AFTER
SHE VICIOUSLY ATTACKED WHITE
FEMALE VOTERS THAT PULLED THE
LEVER FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
REMEMBER THIS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HER LAST STATEMENT ABOUT
WOMEN.
THEY HAVE TO GET APPROVAL FROM
THEIR HUSBANDS, THEIR SONS AND
MALE BOSSES TO VOTE FOR TRUMP.
THAT WAS NOT A GOOD STATEMENT.
NOT GOOD.
NOTICE HOW FAST THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE RUN FROM THESE STATEMENTS
NOW?
THEY ARE DISAVOWING THE
STATEMENTS LIKE I HAVE NEVER
HEARD BEFORE.
SHE'S WRONG.
PEOPLE THAT WERE HER BIGGEST
SUPPORTERS ARE SAYING, WHAT IS
SHE DOING?
WHY DOESN'T SHE JUST GO HOME?
THAT WAS NOT A GOOD STATEMENT.
>> Sean: OF COURSE HILLARY
CLINTON CANNOT STOPPING AND
COMPLAINING ABOUT HER STUNNING
ELECTION DEFEAT AND BLAMING
EVERYBODY.
SHE'S ATTACKING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID IN A RECENT
INTERVIEW.
PATHETIC.
SHE NEEDS TO GET OVER IT.
>> HE HAS UNDERMINED THE OFFICE
AND USED IT TO ENRICH HIMSELF
AND HIS FAMILY.
DISREGARDED LAWS, ETHICAL
STANDARDS.
HE'S CROSSED IN TO A TERRITORY
OF BEHAVIOR AND ACTIONS THAT ARE
UNPREDICTABLE, THAT ARE ERRATIC,
THAT ARE UNDERMINING THE
STABILITY OF THE GLOBAL ORDER.
>> Sean: PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT ENRICHING
YOURSELF?
DID YOU FORGET ABOUT THE 145
MILLION THAT POURED INTO YOUR
FAMILY FOUNDATION, BILL DOUBLING
HIS SPEAKING FEES IN RUSSIA AS
IT RELATES TO -- AND GIVEN THE
SPEECH FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
THE URANIUM ONE SCANDAL?
YOU MAY WANT TO STOP TALKING.
A LOT OF NEWS COMING YOUR
DIRECTION.
BREAKING TONIGHT, HUGE NEWS TO
TELL YOU ABOUT.
MR. DEEP STATE HIMSELF, JAMES
COMEY AND OTHER CORRUPT
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS SHOULD BE
WORRIED TONIGHT.
POLITICO IS REPORTING THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN BOB GOODLATTE
IS GETTING READY TO ISSUE A
SUBPOENA FOR DOCUMENTS THAT THE
DOJ HAS ABOUT THE CORRUPT FBI,
CLINTON E-MAIL INVESTIGATION.
1.2 MILLION DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL, ROD ROSENSTEIN HAS BEEN
DOING EVERYTHING WITHIN HIS
POWER TO NOT LET THE PUBLIC, NOT
LET DEVIN NUNES AND THE HOW
INTEL COMMITTEE AND THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAVE ACCESS
TO THIS INFORMATION.
THE DODGE HAS BEEN STONEWALLING
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
WHY IS THAT?
WHY DOESN'T THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WANT YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, CONGRESSMAN, TO SEE ALL
OF THE DOCUMENTS RELATED TO HOW
POORLY THE CLINTON E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION WAS?
AND WHAT CORRUPTION MAY BE
UNDERLYING ALL OF THIS?
NOW, IT IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
ALREADY KNOWN THAT THE FIX WAS
IN.
THAT THAT INVESTIGATION WAS
RIGGED.
WE KNOW JAMES COMEY, PETER
STRZOK, LISA PAGE, ANDREW McCABE
AND OTHER PEOPLE, SENIOR FBI
OFFICIALS, THEY WERE WRITING
HILLARY'S EXONERATION MONTHS
BEFORE THEY INTERVIEWED HER AND
17 OTHER WITNESSES.
I DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER
INVESTIGATION HANDLED THAT WAY.
IS THERE A SMOKING GUN?
EVIDENCE THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
SEE?
I WOULD ASSUME THE ANSWER IS
YES.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS BEGGING PAUL
RYAN TO STOP DEVIN NUNES AND THE
INTEL COMMITTEE FROM GETTING THE
DOCUMENTS THAT SHOWED SEVERED
FISA ABUSES.
OF COURSE, THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER.
IT'S PAUL RYAN.
HE DID NOT GIVE IN TO
ROSENSTEIN.
OTHERWISE IF HE DID, THERE WOULD
BE NO NUNES MEMO.
THERE WOULD NOT BE A
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO AND WE
WOULDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER THAT WAS USED TO LIE TO
THE FISA COURT.
THE DOJ AND FBI LIED TO THE
JUDGES TO GET THE WARRANT AND
THE EXTENSIONS TO SPY ON CARTER
PAGE AND THE TRUMP ASSOCIATED
AND THE ENTIRE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND ROSENSTEIN IS ROTTEN TO THE
CORE.
ROSENSTEIN SIGNED ONE OR MORE OF
THOSE FISA APPLICATIONS IN CASE
OF THE RENEWAL.
IN OTHER WARDS, THE BULK WERE
MADE UP OF THE DOSSIER.
WHAT DOES ROSENSTEIN HAVE TO
HIDE HERE?
WHY DOES HE PROTECT HIS FRIENDS?
WHY DOES HE HAVE ALL OF THESE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND HOW
CAN HE BE THE GUY THAT APPOINTS
MUELLER AND INVOLVED IN THE
INVESTIGATION WHEN HE HIMSELF
ENGAGED IN POTENTIAL WRONG
DOING?
THINK ABOUT THAT.
WHY DOES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
JEFF SESSIONS, HE HAD TO RECUSE
HIMSELF.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, HE RENEWED THE
FISA APPLICATION.
HE KNEW HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR AND KNEW THE JUDGES WERE
BEING LIED TO.
THEN HE GETS TO A POINT HIS BFF,
ROBERT MUELLER, SPECIAL COUNSEL?
ALL OF THIS IS WHY WE NEED A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THEY CANNOT INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES.
FOR THE CLINTON E-MAIL RECORDS,
MICHAEL HOROWITZ, WE'RE WAITING
ON HIS REPORT.
HE'S GATHERED 1.2 MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
SOME OF WHICH ARE ALL RELATED TO
THIS CORRUPT E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION AND PROBE.
BY THE WAY GUESS HOW MANY OF THE
1.2 DOCUMENTS CONGRESS HAS SEEN?
3,000.
A QUARTER OF 1%.
YOU CALL THAT STONE WALLING 101.
THAT IS THE DEEP STATE
DESPERATELY PROTECTING THE DEEP
STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE'S SOME
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT BELIEVE
IN THEIR ROLE IN OVERSIGHT.
CARE ABOUT TRUTH AND JUST IT'S
THE AND EQUAL APPLICATION AND
EQUAL APPLICATION UNDER THE LAW
AND THE CONSTITUTION.
PEOPLE WILLING TO PUT THEMSELVES
OUT THERE AND FOLLOW THE TRUTH,
THE FACTS, THE EVIDENCE.
ALL RIGHT, ALSO BRAND NEW
TONIGHT, KEVIN McCARTHY, HOUSE
MAJORITY WHIP, STEVE SCALISE,
THEY ARE JOINING THE CHORUS THAT
IS CALLING FOR WHAT WE'VE BEEN
CALLING FOR, THE APPOINTMENT OF
A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THE FACTS, THE EVIDENCE OF WRONG
DOING ARE OVERWHELMING.
HERE'S WHAT CONGRESSMAN McCARTHY
IS SAYING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO WE KNOW THAT McCABE HAS
LIED BY THE INDEPENDENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND NOW HE'S
SAYING ABOUT COMEY, COMEY MAY
HAVE LIED AS WELL.
SO I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE END
OF IT.
BUT THAT IS WHY WE NEED A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I GIVE CHAIRMAN GOWDY AND
GOODLATTE A LOT OF CREDIT AND
ALL OF THOSE MEMBERS.
THEY SENT THE LETTER TO JEFF
SESSIONS.
HE'S LOOKING AT IT.
BUT WE NEED THE ABILITY.
AN INSPECTOR GENERAL DOES NOT
HAVE SUBPOENA POWER OUTSIDE OF
THE DIRECTION.
SO WE NEED SOMEBODY TO LOOK AT
THIS AND NOT FROM THE INSIDE
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T TRUST WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: WELL-SAID.
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE IS OUT WITH
A STATEMENT THAT READS IN PART,
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION WILL BE IN DOUBT
UNLESS WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE SERIOUS QUESTIONS REGARDING
THE FBI'S HANDLING OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AS WELL AS THEIR
INVESTIGATION OR LACK THEREOF
INTO HILLARY CLINTON'S NEGLIGENT
TRANSMISSION OF CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL OVER HER UNAUTHORIZED
E-MAIL SERVER.
THAT'S WHY I AGREE WITH MANY
OTHERS.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED THE
APPOINTMENT OF AN ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL COUNSEL WHO UNLIKE
MUELLER HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
LOOK INTO THE FISA SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOWED THE DEMOCRAT FUNDED
STEELE DOSSIER.
I THOUGHT FOREIGNERS WEREN'T
SUPPOSED TO IMPACT OUR ELECTION
WITH RUSSIAN LIES.
BUT ANYWAY, TO SERVE THE BASIS
FOR THE INITIAL FBI
INVESTIGATION.
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE, CONGRESSMAN
McCARTHY, GRAHAM AND GRASSLEY
AND TILLIS AND CORNYN, THEY'RE
ALL SAYING WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SAYING, THIS GOES ALONG WITH
EVERY SINGLE THING WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO REPORT TO YOU.
THIS IS WHY THIS IS NEEDED, A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
NOW, ROBERT MUELLER
INTERESTINGLY, HE'S BEST FRIENDS
WITH JAMES COMEY.
HE'S BUDDIES WITH ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
HE CANNOT BE INVESTED TO
INVESTIGATE SCANDALS THAT HIS
FRIENDS ARE INVOLVED IN.
COMEY IS AT THE CENTER AS IT
RELATES TO THE CLINTON E-MAIL
FIX.
RIGGING THE INVESTIGATION.
COMEY SAID THE CLINTON DOSSIER
WAS SALACIOUS.
HE SAID THAT IN JANUARY 2017 TO
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP AT TRUMP
TOWER.
IN OCTOBER, 2016, HE WAS USING
THAT SAME DOSSIER, THE ONE HE
SAID IN JANUARY OF 2017 IS
UNVERIFIED AND SALACIOUS TO GET
THE WARRANT TO SPY ON TRUMP
ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE AND HENCE
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEN ROD ROSENSTEIN, LIKE COMEY,
HE SIGNED OFF ON ONE OR MORE OF
THESE FISA RENEWAL APPLICATIONS.
IT'S ONE MASSIVE HUGE DEEP STATE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AFTER
ANOTHER.
THEY'RE PROTECTING THEMSELVES.
THEY'RE TRYING TO PRESERVE THEIR
OWN POWER.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN
IF WE WANT LAW AND ORDER TO
REIGN IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS.
WE HAVE TO LITERALLY DRAIN THE
SWAMP AND THE SEWER.
THAT BRINGS US TO OUR SPECIAL
INVESTIGATION.
WHO IS ROBERT MUELLER?
EVERYBODY SAYS HE'S THE GREATEST
GUY IN THE WHOLE WORLD.
TRUST US.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THEY'VE BEEN
TRYING TO CONVINCE YOU THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS BEYOND
REPROACH.
SORT OF LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE.
NOBODY DISAGREES WITH US.
NO SCIENTIST DOES.
THAT'S NOT TRUE EITHER.
MUELLER IS THE UTMOST MAN OF
INTEGRITY.
WE'VE BEEN DOING SOME DIGGING.
WE FOUND SOME THINGS YOU NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT.
TONIGHT WATER GOING TO TELL YOU
WHO ROBERT MUELLER REALLY IS.
A NEW REPORT FROM INVESTIGATOR
SARAH CARTER.
ROBERT MUELLER'S CAREER HAS BEEN
ANYTHING BUT IMPECCABLE.
ONE OF THE WORST STAINS ON HIS